let's break the internet let's print
debit let's break the Internet
let's break the Internet
[Music]
in and out versus Shake Shack if you're
like me you're over it but to be honest
they're both awesome what I want to
break down is how to make them at home
especially when you're stuck in the city
where you can't get the buff so I linked
up with Andrew rain for my favorite
YouTube channel binging with babish to
put our culinary chops to the test it's
a hack these two legendary burgers the
Shake Shack double Shack and the in and
out double-double animal style do you
think it's even fair to compare in and
out and shake shake shake Shack burger
to me is like more of like a higher-end
burger than it is in and out and it now
it's more like exactly what it is in
California it's just more chill
under-promise over-deliver tech burger I
can't compare the two of these it's
definitely seat that's getting out can
you explain that to me it's California
oh yeah I mean in and out it's like the
burger Church it's like the burger Mecca
for Californians so as a Californian you
know dude I'm special I'm eating this
because someone in Indianapolis can't
have this right now I mean what do you
think that major differences are I went
to Shake Shack early on it was just one
of the best burgers I had ever had
because it was in between a sit-down
restaurants you know bleed all over the
place burger and a fast-food burger
let's have to cook a meal let's see this
double shock
[Music]
one important part of the Shack burger
is that they use potato rolls
specifically Martin Pater rolls which
are the best of the world right there
you know they're squishy they're a
little sweeter they're just they're my
personal favorite for a burger and now
making the special sauce over here which
starts with as most burger special
sauces do mayo and ketchup and
apparently they throw a little bit of
pickle brine in there well pinches of
garlic powder paprika onion powder and I
am just like tiniest little bit okay we
got a mixture of short rib brisket what
is that like their real recipe or is
that your recipe their real recipe is a
secret and it's just my best yes this
right here guys is Wyatt a fox we're
talking about premium quality beef
minerally Flatiron beefy in the brisket
then you get that like function s of a
short rib I'm making my mouth water so
one of the most important things about
this burger one of the things that makes
it a shake back burger is the smash
burger patty and which is one of my
favorite ways to make burgers at home we
got two ounce meatballs and we're just
gonna throw those in each corner of our
skillet here my favorite American cheese
all over this is what we're putting on
these burgers always and you hear that
you the cheese melt expert was right
it's like 45 seconds or something I like
it when it's barely melted on the edges
yeah then I let the carryover he take
care of the rough you get that gooey
near site that makes a burger addictive
yeah just stack those up I'm gonna get
tomatoes going here Shake Shack also
uses roma tomatoes in place of one big
beefsteak tomato actually is what's in
turnout uses we start with patties on
the bottom no sauce on the butter
tomatoes three slices of tomatoes if I
remember correctly then we're going
lettuce sauce these look messy but tell
me anytime you've ever even a Shack
burger with clean hands that's kind of
like the whole thing if it doesn't get
all over your face it's not worth eating
let's try this bathwater chef's it might
not look identical to the Shake Shack
burger but it's [ __ ] fantastic gooey
cheese mixed with equal read the others
roll squishes down in them you know two
o'clock in the morning cross-eyed drunk
it's just the best when I'm not working
and I'm making stuff at home
I like the imperfections because when
you have those imperfections like the
crispy bits like when you smashed it
those crispy bits that were left over
really play a factor on the textures of
this and you don't get that at the
restaurant that's what they say but what
wood is strengthened by it's nuts we're
gonna do the in-and-out double-double
animal style so animal style in burger
form means add pickles caramelized
onions extra spread and the patties are
glazed in yellow mustard the difference
between this burger button and the
potato bun is more of like a Wonder
Bread style shout out to Kenji serious
eats Heat he breaks down what's on the
spread so it's about 62% Mayo and then
he says it's 38% ketchup and relish now
I'm gonna go by color just go with you
know your gut feeling I mean this looks
like spread to me yeah
well seasoned with salt make a season
both sides are just one side on this I'm
gonna season one side and I can get away
with that because these patties are way
thinner than the Shake Shack patties I
know that their beef comes from central
California but there's no specific blend
oh I see all right what's the advantage
of the grill it griddling patties in
lovely you know what it just adds this
extra layer of crust I've tried it with
Grey Poupon
Grayden mustard and none of it works as
well as bright yellow nucular
mustard like this once you're done with
that you're ready to flip I see what the
musters doing let's see it alright it's
grouting I wasn't expecting that
oh yeah that's what you want man then
we'll just throw the cheese on top all
right and another key step to the animal
cell right when it gets to this point
here where the cheese almost adheres to
the beef yeah on the bottom that had it
was hit with a caramelized onion now I
like extra spread I do extra spread its
top and bottom ooh we're doing four
pickles
whoops now I'm gonna East LA it up a
little bit and we're gonna throw banana
chilies you know when you get this up
the restaurant you just say add chopped
chilies to it yeah and these are
chopping out chilies the same ones that
they use over there I welcome the other
choice tomatoes on the bottom one slice
of beef steak lettuce was on top of that
their lettuce is actually cut in
triangle so you went to that so I went
yeah I want that level and there you go
in and out double-double animal style
all right let's let's eat this like
there's a little bit pink in the bird
which is awesome in and out you can
actually choose your doneness the
aromatic of onions man really I feel is
the definition of an in-n-out burger
like you have to have onions whenever
someone orders a burger without onions I
just give them a look like why not the
difference between the in-n-out burger
that I made today and the in-and-out
burger that we can get at the restaurant
is I feel like the assembly line of the
restaurant makes it stack so perfectly
and then it's wrapped yeah right and I
feel like the wrapping almost creates a
flavor envelope and makes the experience
that much better
so we've done the Shake Shack we've done
that in and out let's just put it
together it makes them in and out Shake
Shack babies you're a madman first
things first the fun let's cut the
potato buns in half sauce sauce I like
to in and out sauce I like the
chunkiness the bite of the relish let's
throw those seasonings in there
yes there are a couple splices yeah
what's the powder garlic powder Cayenne
paprika oh yeah that's oh my gosh that's
good take it to the next level
vegetables
I think iceberg iceberg is good yeah cuz
that that butter lettuce is intrusive
it's it's to metal yeah I got a bit
crunch
I'm almost saying 86 to Tomatoes man
maybe what I don't even need it no
tomatoes at all let's break some rules
yeah pickles the chilies
I can go with ear I think not to be but
I don't like to think just because I
don't like your thickness okay I would
say we go Chili's cool that's two
Chili's alright so what are we doing for
B I so use the Shake Shack blend
flavorful is expensive it's rich it's
it's beefy it has a great reaction when
it hits the griddle yeah I definitely
think that we should put some yellow
mustard on there let's go three ounce
patties three ounce patties yeah oh man
all right I love the beef man so let's
do it
let's break the internet let's put debit
babish style
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the best sound of the world oh
yeah - animal style it up let's get some
mustard on that bad boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she's loved she's um up you start to see
the criminalization on that mustard map
I love this on the in-n-out burger extra
soft extra spread veg on the bottom I
think these are much beautiful burgers
oh yeah in the world
we literally squashed East Coast West
Coast beef here today in this kitchen
unity all right time to eat let's get a
shot that's a good darn good burn that's
a marriage made in heaven
see this what happens when people put
aside their differences and just get
along
turns out the unity between shake
shacking in and out is actually what we
wanted all along this is the home burger
that I've dreamt of this is a mother
burger show baby we out
[Music]
so we are Kelly jay-z this bad boy best
of both worlds
[Laughter]